what is um amazing to me is if i talk to  someone who is so  steadfast hatred for donald trump  i this is unbelievable and this is where  you have to say cuckoo  they hate him so much they'd rather be  they pay their seven dollars or five  dollars for gas than to have gas at a  dollar fifty or a dollar now here's the  other thing you go to the supermarket  you know groceries were very reasonable  when donald trump was in office now you  go to buy a gallon of milk it's like six  dollars right yes everybody has to pay  the same thing whether you're hispanic  or african american or whatever  everybody goes to supermarket they don't  ask for your voter registration card  it's amazing though that biden has been  able to use as a scapegoat  for his failures  placing it directly on donald trump